Traduttore: Jolanda Gerosa
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Si, avventurarsi in acque inesplorate,
spingersi in territori sconosciuti,
superare la propria conoscenza
per spostare i propri confini
sempre un po' oltre.
La sete di scoperta è da sempre
uno dei tratti più distintivi
e a mio parere straordinari
dello spirito umano.
Qualcosa che ha caratterizzato
e continua a far crescere
il nostro percorso evolutivo
come specie.
La storia che vorrei condividere
con voi oggi
inizia circa otto anni fa quando,
affacciato alla finestra
di un grattacielo newyorkese,
mi ritrovavo in una fase della mia vita
in cui avevo letteralmente
perso la bussola.
Avevo una carriera di successo
nel mondo della moda
e nonostante mi ritrovassi all'apice,
paradossalmente ero precipitato al fondo
in una vera e propria crisi esistenziale.
Quel mondo di luci e di eccessi,
quell'immagine comune della bella vita
che ci viene propinata da film e pubblicità,
non mi andava più,
non mi sentivo soddisfatto.
Non mi piaceva più
quello che stavo facendo
e ancor meno quello che stavo diventando.
Ero letteralmente arrivato al limite.
La vita nella grande mela
mi stava stretta, mi sentivo in gabbia,
sentivo la bruciante necessità di evadere
e avevo un'inarrestabile
sete di avventura.
E' stato proprio in quel momento
che ho scoperto l'ultramaratona
attraverso Ultramarathon Man,
la biografia di questo Dean Karnazes,
in cui racconta la sua trasformazione
da businessman di successo
a ultrarunner, appunto.
Quello che più mi colpiva era
come avesse raggiunto il successo materiale
però, nonostante tutto,
non si sentisse soddisfatto.
E la sua storia mi toccava da vicino
e mi ritrovavo in ogni sua parola.
Ero rimasto estremamente affascinato
dal suo salto nel vuoto.
Aveva abbandonato la strada vecchia
per intraprenderne una tutta nuova
e aveva trovato, investendo in se stesso,
significato e profondità
nel correre distanze enormi
in ambienti sempre più estremi.
Tutti sappiamo di cosa si tratta
quando si parla di corsa,
ma molti di voi si chiederanno
che cosa sia questo ultrarunning.
Come tutti sappiamo,
una maratona è di 42 km
e come tutti sono cresciuto
con il mito di questo evento,
che ha le radici nella Grecia classica,
considerandola la sfida definitiva
oltre la quale il nostro corpo
semplicemente non potesse spingersi.
Una vera prova di resistenza e resilienza
che porta ai limiti
del proprio potenziale fisico.
Ora, trasformate una maratona
in un'ultramaratona
e la sfida va ben oltre il fisico,
diventa mentale.
Ecco, un'ultramaratona è qualsiasi distanza
che va oltre quei famigerati 42 km.
Quindi dai 50 km, ai 100 km,
ai 200 km, a volte anche di più.
E poi c'è questa leggendaria sfida,
di cui parla proprio Karnazes nel suo libro:
la badwater 135, considerata la gara
podistica più dura del mondo.
Ben 217 km attraverso la valle della morte,
il posto più caldo del pianeta,
ovviamente non poteva non essere corsa
che nel bel mezzo dell'estate.
Questo la rende non solo una sfida
di resilienza, ma quasi di sopravvivenza,
con temperature che arrivano
a sfiorare i 55 gradi.
Da allora decisi di lasciare
quella carriera che tanto mi stava stretta
per dedicarmi con tutto me stesso
a questa disciplina
che in pochi anni si è trasformata
nella mia vita.
Ad oggi ho corso oltre 25 ultramaratone
in alcuni degli ambienti più belli
e a volte inospitali
che il pianeta possa offrire.
Probabilmente penserete tutti
che sia una pazzia
e la domanda più comune
è sempre la stessa: perché?
Oppure: ma chi te lo fa fare?
Ciò che mi affascina maggiormente
di questa disciplina è proprio che si tratta
di un concetto assoluto, stimolante
che rimette in discussione
tutti gli schemi sociali
e i limiti con cui siamo cresciuti.
In un'epoca in cui
tutte le terre sono già state esplorate,
tutte le montagne più alte
sono già state scalate,
ogni angolo del globo
è già stato scoperto,
sembrerebbe che l'unica vera esplorazione
rimasta sia l'esplorazione del sé.
Andare nelle profondità dell'anima
oltre qualsiasi limite fisico.
Penso che alla base della mia scelta
ci sia stata proprio questa necessità
di entrare in contatto con me stesso
e sentirmi realmente vivo.
L'eccitazione e la felicità che sperimentiamo
durante una nuova esperienza,
il superare gli ostacoli
che si presentano sul cammino,
diventano un modo di scoprire le nostre
capacità, facendoci sentire più sicuri
e in un certo modo vivi.
A volte ci vuole un'avventura per mostrarci
quanto sia ricco e variegato il mondo là fuori
e ci rendiamo conto che
la nostra prospettiva non è l'unica
e che c'è sempre di più da vedere,
sempre di più da fare
e sempre di più da imparare.
Il filosofo americano Thoreau
una volta disse:
"molti uomini vivono una vita
di quieta disperazione".
Lo stile di vita moderno ci ha dato tutto
ma non ci rende mai soddisfatti.
Il perché è forse dato dal fatto che,
preferendo uno stile di vita
fatto di confort e false sicurezze,
ci siamo estraniati da ciò che più conta:
la crescita personale
e il contatto con il proprio io.
A volte ci vuole anche una caduta
per insegnarci quanto siamo forti,
ingenosi e coraggiosi.
Tutti noi abbiamo punti di forza nascosti
che non sempre conosciamo
ed è solo misurandoci con noi stessi
che scopriamo le nostre capacità,
le nostre potenzialità.
Dopotutto, se ci atteniamo semplicemente
alla nostra routine quotidiana,
non sfidandoci mai
a provare qualcosa di nuovo,
come potremmo mai scoprire
il nostro vero valore?
Ogni avventura ci arricchisce e aiuta
a vedere il mondo sotto una nuova luce.
Chiaramente il percorso sarà
sempre pieno di ostacoli
e i fallimenti saranno sempre
dietro l'angolo.
Ma se c'è una cosa che ho imparato è che
i fallimenti sono una parte fondamentale
sulla via del successo,
poiché ci permettono di crescere
e di imparare dai nostri errori.
Ogni errore, appunto, comporta
una nuova scelta, una nuova decisione
che certamente modella il nostro destino.
Ed è proprio con questo spirito
che ha avuto inizio questo mio percorso
nel mondo delle ultra.
In questa meravigliosa disciplina
non si tratta solo di corsa,
si parla di qualcosa di più:
andare oltre, la curiosità di scoprire
cosa succede oltre quel limite fisico,
quando il dolore è cosi insopportabile
che tutto il tuo corpo ti supplica di fermarti.
C'è stato un episodio particolare che si è
rivelato di grandissimo insegnamento per me
ed è proprio di questo
che vi vorrei parlare oggi.
Era l'inizio del 2016 e dopo alcuni anni
di esperienze ultra in giro per il mondo
decisi di sfidare i miei limiti
ulteriormente e inviare la mia richiesta
proprio alla badwater 135,
la gara più dura del pianeta.
Sono solo 100 gli ultrarunner esperti,
provenienti da tutto il mondo,
che vengono selezionati ogni anno.
Passano poche settimane,
la risposta e l'invito a partecipare:
ero dentro!
Era la sfida che avevo sempre sognato,
la gara ultra per eccellenza.
Volevo sperimentare in prima persona
cosa volesse dire ritrovarsi là fuori,
nelle condizioni più estreme,
con solo le mie gambe e il mio cuore,
attraverso un ambiente così selvaggio
e inospitale.
E' così che il 17 luglio del 2016
mi ritrovai al badwater basin,
un lago salato essiccato
a 90 m sotto il livello del mare,
il punto più basso degli Stati Uniti,
con davanti a me 217 km di strada infuocata
fino al mount Whitney,
il punto più alto di 48 stati contigui.
Il countdown e poi un grande urlo a darci il via,
mentre il gruppo si snodava rapidamente
nell'immensa valle davanti a noi.
La gara era iniziata alle 23,
quindi alle 11 di sera,
con un'accogliente temperatura di 45 gradi.
A seguirci, un veicolo per il team
di supporto, obbligatorio per la sicurezza
e per provvedere a soddisfare tutte le necessità
e le esigenze di ogni singolo corridore,
poiché ogni singolo corridore deve abituarsi
a ingerire fino a due litri di acqua ogni ora.
Dopo circa due ore di corsa, ritrovandomi
con una borraccia vuota in mano,
inizio a cercare il mio veicolo
tra tutti quelli che mi ronzavano intorno.
Cominciavo a sentirmi sempre più
disidratato, data la temperatura esorbitante,
ma per qualche motivo
non c'era traccia del mio team.
Intanto passa un km,
poi ne passa un altro
eppure nessun segno della mia squadra.
Dopo quasi un'ora finalmente,
un volto familiare si avvicina,
esce dall'oscurità della notte e io,
completamente disorientato
e fortemente disidratato, decido di
schiantarmi sul sedile posteriore del van
cercando di recuperare
e riprendere le energie.
Per qualche motivo, nel casino della partenza
e nell'oscurità della notte,
mi avevano perso in questo tratto iniziale
e a quel punto il mio stomaco
era già sottosopra, la mia mente allucinava
e il mio corpo era già a pezzi.
Bene, mi dissi.
Tieniti forte, mancano solo altri 180 km.
Nonostante questo pesante pensiero
ero determinato a finire
e non importava come,
a dire la verità.
Quell'avventura era iniziata in modo
ben diverso da quello che avevo immaginato,
ma credo che in un certo modo
sia questo il bello dell'avventura,
non sai mai quello che può succedere.
Così, un passo dopo l'altro,
ripresi la mia corsa,
che fu una vera e propria via crucis devo dire.
Mi ero trascinato tutta la notte,
poi attraverso il calore estenuante
del giorno successivo e a quel punto,
al tramonto del secondo giorno,
il mio corpo non riusciva più
a muovere un passo.
Forti ondate di dolore
mi attraversavano la schiena,
quando mi resi conto che non avevo fatto
la pipì dal giorno precedente.
I miei reni erano letteralmente in fiamme.
Così decisi di fermarmi ancora una volta,
una breve pausa per cercare di bere il più possibile
e poco dopo il liquido rosso che uscì
mi lasciò senza parole.
Preoccupato per la mia salute
ero incerto su cosa fare.
Certe decisioni definiscono chi siamo
e mentre ero seduto in quel van
immerso nel dolore,
guardando gli altri corridori che passavano,
iniziai a scavare dentro di me cercando tutta
la motivazione e l'ispirazione possibile
per non arrendermi.
Poi d'improvviso mi alzai,
tutto bruciato dal sole,
con le gambe dure e una sensazione
di un persistente pugno nello stomaco,
mettendo un piede davanti all'altro,
alla fine tagliai quel traguardo
così tanto agognato.
Dopo 34 ore di costante movimento
e dopo tutto quello che avevo passato,
ero chiaramente felice di aver portato
a termine quello che mi ero prefissato ma,
in tutta onestà, dentro di me
non ero assolutamente soddisfatto.
Fu un duro colpo sia per il mio fisico
che per il mio orgoglio
e mi leccai le ferite per molto tempo.
Passano due anni e decido di ritentare l'impresa,
richiedendo una nuova partecipazione.
E' così che il 24 luglio proprio di quest'anno,
mi ritrovo sulla linea di partenza,
deciso a rimettermi in discussione.
Ci sono molti momenti in cui mi risuona
in testa la famosa frase di Steve Jobs:
"Stay hungry, stay foolish".
Mi ricorda quanto sia importante
non sentirsi mai arrivati
e che bisogna sempre e comunque
spingersi oltre.
Questo vuol dire continuare a provare
e riprovare anche quando tutto intorno a noi
dice che non sia possibile.
Quest'anno, dopo 24 ore di corsa ininterrotta,
sono immensamente onorato di poter dire
non solo di aver concluso,
ma di aver vinto la badwater 135.
Un cercho iniziato 7 anni fa
con una sua perfetta conclusione.
Il sogno di una vita realizzato.
La mia vittoria più grande è di non essermi
arreso davanti al fallimento iniziale
e di aver colto quest'ulteriore opportunità.
Sono qui oggi ad incoraggiarvi ad avventurarvi
nell'ignoto, a rischiare e a fallire,
per crescere e spingervi oltre voi stessi
e oltre i vostri limiti,
per vivere pienamente, per vivere veramente.
E' solo quando viviamo una vita
intenzionale, con scopo,
facendo ciò che amiamo fare
ed essendo ciò che vogliamo essere,
che troviamo pienezza e felicità
dentro noi stessi.
Tutti abbiamo ambizioni
ma troppo spesso abbiamo paura di rischiare.
Tutti abbiamo paura di non essere
abbastanza bravi, abbastanza forti,
abbastanza intelligenti.
Ci sentiamo intrappolati dai limiti
che percepiamo, perdendoci inesorabilmente
nella paura di fallire ed è lì che tendiamo
a perdere fiducia in noi stessi.
Ma credo sia assolutamente necessario
correre quel rischio, sbagliare e rialzarsi,
superando quelle paure per liberarsi
e trovare se stessi e la propria voce.
In ogni passo che facciamo nell'ignoto
scopriamo la nostra forza
e la nostra perseveranza
per raggiungere quei sogni.
E' proprio nel processo di crescita che
realizziamo di essere tutti molto più capaci
di quello che abbiamo sempre creduto.
Solo così ci evolviamo e ci spingiamo verso
una versione sempre migliore di noi stessi.
Un sé più cosciente,
più soddisfatto e più grato.
Quindi, in qualsiasi direzione
vogliate proseguire nella vostra vita,
non abbiate paura di avventurarvi oltre.
Fate quel passo senza restrizione alcuna
e lasciate che il vostro meraviglioso viaggio abbia inizio.
Grazie mille.
(applausi)